Hey Youtubers happy Super Bowl weekend, things
are going to be crazy new footage let's break
it down.
The funny thing about this is just the idea
that she is a feral animal in the way that
Wolverine was a feral animal when Professor
X first started working with him.
So the big joke is just in this adorable little
girl being crazy inappropriate just like Wolverine
getting ready to chop everyone's heads off
there's going to be a whole lot more of this
this weekend from all the other studios so
I'll be posted trailer videos be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
There's going to be a giveaway going on that
I'll explain at the end of the video but right
now this little girl is my favorite new female
character in any Marvel movie from any studio
and there are a whole lot of really powerful
female characters but she just totally wins
you over with her craziness, so appropriate
given the battle that's gonna be happening
on the football field.
they're playing up the funny moments, but
you see how this is a mirror of that X-2 see
where Wolverine himself almost flips out on
someone when he's grabbing a beer there.
also hyping up It runs in the family so there
being more open about who she is where she
comes from.
I did another video about X-23 herself.
So at a link at the end of this she's essentially
a clone of Wolverine, but in the comics her
relationship with Logan is a little more contentious
she's grown to a full adult and that she's
more of a child so she becomes more of a daughter
to him.
The other funny thing they've explained you
see him driving Professor X around in the
back of his car here driving her around.
Is that when he's been hiding out in this
town on the border of Mexico he's been working
as a limousine driver the great and powerful
Wolverine working as a limo driver because
he Professor X, shaking his fist in the back
asking for sandwiches.
The funny thing about that like we were just
talking about that X-2 scene with Wolverine
in the cat in X2 he's driving around that
band of young X-Men I've always felt like
Wolverine works best when you pair him with
younger characters that are more innocent
he the super hard-core dude who was forced
to confront his humanity when he sees these
innocent people that need his help save the
will go storm in general Boston that way but
Harrison in the really cool thing that I'm
excited for really from all superhero movies
Marvel is doing this to all explain at the
end of the video is more intimate small crossovers
like this there's also been a couple really
important people that have come out and explain
those comics that she is walking around with
to, so was really clear from the previous
trailers, just because it was like really
lo-res but it says X-Men comics group basically
fake comics that were made for the movie by
Joe Quesada, Mr. Marvel himself he used to
be Marvel's creative director, but he was
an artist for a long time.
Wrote a bunch of comics so he and another
artist made those covers specifically for
this movie, just because of that weird copyright
issues with them actually using real Marvel
comics in the movies so I know it sounds weird
but adjustment to hype up the idea of all
these crazy adventures in the legends of the
X-Men inside the universe of this film and
a lot of people are asking to about Hugh Jackman
making a comment saying that it's not in the
same universe is the main X-Men films, the
director James Mangold came out after that
and said that people probably misinterpreted
what he was saying or he misspoke a little
bit because is not completely set in a different
universe just set right after that.
Post credit scene in days of Future past in
the future timeline that they've fixed.
Where everyone still alive if you haven't
seen that movie in a while what happens is
is that this is post-apocalyptic timeline
with an older version of all the characters
that are still alive.
They banded together with magneto's brotherhood
of mutants, so they send Wolverine into the
past, to try and change things for the better
their successful and when Wolverine wakes
up he wakes up in the X mansion which hasn't
been destroyed and it was sort of Brian Singer's
way to wave his hand over all the craziness
that it happened after he left the franchise.
So X3 was gone.
Jean Grey was alive, she had become the Phoenix
he wasn't forced to kill her Professor X is
back and he has this brief memory of what
used to happen because he's reading Logan's
mind and Logan's the only one that remembers
this previous timeline didn't divorce Logan.
Don't you have a trust to each class to teach
history.
History should I can use him out with a help
with what pretty much everything after 1973
in the
history I notice little different it's good
to see Charles see everyone well.
I have a promise to keep you have a lot of
catching up to do this movie set many years
after that Logan's varied most of his friends
he's trying to take care Professor X who is
slowly dying himself but still very powerful,
but they released a little more footage explaining
a little bit about the pockets of other mutants
that are still alive that they're trying to
find.
So it's not like the last mutants on the planet
but you guys can let me know.
Because this is that so far in the future.
How do you want them to reincorporate the
characters in the future films because I'll
do a separate video about it some point because
it's almost like the Deadpool universe now
the way the characters become so popular he's
influencing the way the thinking about doing
crossover movies they said that they're doing
the Marvel phase for style thing where the
gonna do a lot of smaller crossovers mixed
with the bigger tent pole films which if you
didn't know is basically was happening in
Marvel phase 4 though still be the big avengers
crossovers, but most of the films that you
see will be crossover movies so like Iron
Man showing up in a Spider-Man film winter
soldier showing backup during Black Panther
things like that they'll be more crossover
movies the still be very cool, very big movies
it just that you're headed up for a lot of
people popping up in other people's movies
so the same thing I think is going to be happening
with the DC movies.
And with the X-Men Fox movies so that actually
makes me really excited.
I totally loved the smaller films.
I think Logan is going to be amazing.
There's gonna be a whole bunch more Super
Bowl trailer stuff happening this weekend
so I'll try to post that as fast as possible
just explained that giveaway I mentioned at
the beginning of the video to because the
movie is coming out in a couple weeks which
is awesome it's for IMAX gift certificates,
gift certificates, even if the movies not
in IMAX.
So standard rules apply.
All you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll announce
winners as I post the new Super Bowl trailer
video so make sure you check those out as
I post them as long as you have alerts enabled,
you should be able to get everything, but
I do have the teaser for grant Gustin getting
a new version of the flash suit.
So I'll post that next, but you guys can let
me know if you want me to do another video
for that other Wolverine Logan footage while
you wait for that to post you can click here
for more Super Bowl trailers and you can click
here to learn all about X-23 Thank you so
much for watching everybody high five I'll
see the next video!